joining us now from Grand Rapids is
Donald Trump jr. by the way we want to
give a shout out to WX mi Fox 17 for
helping us get this shot up Don great to
see you thanks for joining us you've
been surrounded since the moment you
walked in that building today but you
and your family have been through over
two years now of never ending attack
speculation collusion jail all of it and
yet no collusion no obstruction in the
end and I want to get first to reaction
your general reaction well listen it's
great but most importantly I really it
while it's been an incredible
vindication for me for my father for our
entire family it's really been a great
vindication for all those incredible
hardworking Americans the deplorable who
stuck with us through all of the
nonsense through all of the lies sold to
us by CNN MSNBC you know the tinfoil hat
Brigade that is Adam Schiff and Eric
swallow well and those clowns you know
it's really nice and Sean when you look
at what my father's accomplished in the
last two years when you look at his
winning track record despite the largest
witch hunt the greatest hoax ever
perpetrated on the American people
imagine what he can do now with that
cloud off of his back I think it's going
to be a big deal and I think America is
gonna win because of it you know you
know you talk about tinfoil hat
conspiracies
that's for TV and yeah Adam Schiff you
know but now you got oh let's start all
over again
you got six to eight congressional
committees they want to drag everybody
back by the way a lot of people can't
afford attorneys and their lives and the
stress and the pressure of you know
being grilled on the same issue now this
it will be the fifth investigation well
Sean I've done 27 hours and changed
myself on a 20 minute meeting for
example that's about three times more
than Hillary Clinton spent on Benghazi
while Secretary of State I was a
civilian on a campaign that just goes to
show you the double standard but I was
blessed because I could afford lawyers
to do this not everyone could spend
seven figures defending themselves and
that
all this has been this has been a way
for the left and their media lackeys to
try to drive people in the ground try to
drive those supporters into our ground
and that's why this has been such a
great vindication and it's so important
for us you know again my father's track
record speaks for itself but he's going
to do even more now that he has that
monkey off his back you know when you
talk about all that everyone goes
through and here's the other big story
is there was Russia collusion you know I
have it ensemble cast on this show and
for two straight years with real
evidence we have pointed out a rigged
investigation into Hillary lying and
committing fraud on a FISA Court we have
pointed out again and again and again
that people note knew from the beginning
that this was unverified but then they
used it to spy on the campaign deny the
constitutional rights a quarter-page
what what do you think needs to be done
to ensure as your father said on this
program last night this never happens to
another president well listen they have
to get to the bottom of it no one wants
to move on more than I do I'd love to
see bipartisanship I'd love to see the
Democrats get onboard and maybe work on
infrastructure maybe works for the
American people for a change
rather than just trying to take out
someone who's done an incredible job if
the Democrats had actual real policies
that they could run on and win on you
know maybe they should do that but they
don't so maybe they should get on board
with these winning policies for America
and do that but you've had the comas
over the world this trucks the McCabe's
John Brennan the former head of the CIA
going on there saying well we're aware
of this collusion that's been going on
for you oh I got bad information I'm
sorry I've been saying it and screaming
it like a lunatic for two years and all
of a sudden oh I got bad information
let's move on we have to get to the
bottom of it Shawn because this can't
happen again this has been a stain on
our Republic it's a blight on democracy
and our Constitution and it can't be
allowed to happen again to either side
this is you know a partisan issue
this is something it should never happen
again
it's the greatest hoax ever perpetrated
on the American people and it was done
by Hillary Clinton the DNC
ninety-three percent of the mainstream
media the media has done irreparable
damage to themselves and their
reputation to two or three people even
the two or three people on the Left had
tried to report it honestly and said you
know maybe we're getting a little in
over our skis they got killed they got
lambasted for the last few years they're
the only ones that have been vindicated
it's gonna take a long time to heal and
the only way we're gonna heal is if we
know how this farce actually started
well I think when you listen if you
deleted 33,000 emails cleaned your hard
drive in the process of all this and
busted up your devices or had an aide
bust them up with hammers and remove SIM
cards oh and then if you committed a
fraud before a FISA Court omit telling
that that the opposition party paid for
this dossier it was never verified
the author of the dossier doesn't stand
by it but you present it to a court not
once but four times the bulk of
information the Grassley grandmother was
the flying Hillary Russian dossier
Russian of all things correct only
Hillary Clinton and maybe justice
Millette could get away with that kind
of farce Sean yeah you know you
mentioned something about your father's
success record low unemployment he's
talking about it tonight of more African
Americans Hispanic Americans Asian
Americans women in the workplace youth
unemployment new leaves we're going on
five and a half million new jobs now
economic growth we haven't seen in over
a decade
and I have never not one time watched on
any of these other so-called news
networks any reporting on this great
story that has taken millions off of
food stamps and out of poverty and
created a ladder to success well Sean it
doesn't fit the narrative it doesn't
work you know the business guy who left
a billionaire lifestyle to do this for
the American people that's not a story
the Democrats want you know they need a
Joe Biden they need a swamp creature in
there to keep perpetuating the nonsense
to keep perpetuating their failed
policies and frankly to take their
failed policies even further by now
implement vast MPO aspects of socialism
into that policy
it's failed a thousand times but they're
gonna get it right this time Shawn you
know I've known your dad and your family
for a lot of years your dad over two
decades and I know that this this has to
wear on you what was the toughest moment
for you you know the reality is as a
tried and true American you know being
called a traitor every day having you
know people chime in on social media
well your kids are gonna enjoy seeing
you behind bars
I've been day in and day out you know
it's pretty brutal now I know it's
nonsense because I was actually there
but it still gets to you it still wears
on you especially when you take sort of
your patriotism as seriously as I do and
so you know that was rough even though
you know it's nonsense unfortunately
with life you still have to deal with
nonsense but now that that's over other
than you know a few of the lunatics you
know on the left it's pretty exciting
and we can go back to winning you know
the sad thing is they'll never admit
they're wrong sad thing is you know I
remember for example dog there's no
culpability because on their side Sean
you don't need to because there's no
accountability there you don't need
accountability to keep doing what you do
they just do it because it's part of the
narrative and everyone's in on it you
know my father I mean he was talking
about the deep state back in 2016 and
most people like I don't know if that's
real if the last two years have shown us
anything is that is very real and very
alive and we are combating it hard and
he's gonna keep doing that you know
we've had a great ensemble here and
we've been right the whole time and the
media's been wrong the whole time and I
know they're never gonna stop they're
just gonna move on to the next series of
Lies and misinformation but I don't as
you say think they ever get their trust
back again all right here's a question a
lot of people want to know you know
you've been out on the stump a lot
lately a lot of people think crowds
you're drawing do you ever think about
it maybe one day you want to run yeah
look right now I'll never rule anything
out I do enjoy it I like being in the
fight I like being in the mix I like
seeing you know the difference it's
making to real working-class families
all over the country Sean and you know I
get that I'm you know the son of a
billionaire from New York City but I
think everyone knows and anyway
see me on the campaign trail knows I
have friends in flyover country I've
spent time with them over the years
hunting fishing competitive shooting all
over those things I mean I actually
spend much more time here than I do at
the rubber chicken charity dinner
circuit in New York City these are my
people I get it so you know watching it
make a difference to them watching them
you know recapture their American dream
that American dream that's been exported
to foreign countries most of whom hate
our guts for the last few decades that's
a huge deal for me and I see what my
father's doing and I'm just damn proud
as an American to see those results and
I'm gonna keep fighting for him I won't
rule it out for myself but first things
first we're gonna let him finish up
strong all right Don jr. thank you for
being with us and yeah it took an FBI
investigation to congressional
investigations now the Muller report and
these insane tinfoil hat people want to
continue thank you for being with us
tonight thank you very much John great
speaking dear